welcome as you play cool with that
wizard yeah that's Grand Master Dimitri
Yakko Wenk oh yeah that's one of the
highest rated players that she can get
on the ICC his 2740 or something so like
a top top 20 awesome top 20 guy this
kind of this kind of ranking so we got a
new mizzou Indian classical and that
line that is playing here is interesting
with d6 and night b7 it's something that
I had considered for my book actually as
a as a as an alternative to my main
recommendation the the Zurich variation
I ultimately did not unfit in the book
because black has to be very flexible
there was a spawn structures and I
didn't want to present that in the book
held a little bit yeah a little bit not
straightforward enough sometimes black
plays with b6 sometimes it plays with c5
it's interesting I'm kind of curious
okay is going for this kind of setup I'm
trying to be ready to recapture on c3
with and wide so that I don't have to
move my queen that doesn't look too bad
for white what should be a little bit
better here I mean nothing nothing
brilliant but something okay let's do
this and see maybe he will take here
play rook c8 try to go for No
so what am i doing like before it seems
seems right yeah gaining space
ok Quincy seven ism non-committal
improvement move okay if I should go
like Bishop to g3 but I don't want
Bishop g 39 h 5 this is why I went age
three maybe this is an idea yeah i saw
that idea but i thought it should be two
should be good isn't that good I don't
mind that anyway Bishop to e2 whoa so
he's saying that g4 is not losing a
piece due to jeju-do to what Quincy six
I could be five
so G for you placed five really whoa
okay she takes age five yeah that's
maybe maybe correct
I have a hard time to believe in that
have to be honest even though is a
strong player if I go queen d 1 what is
this move she's six or what
but yet position really weird stuff is
he doing now just six and that's very
ugly stuff mmm okay anyway if I go d5
and simply yes it takes 45 takes on h5
that's not really that great let's do
this sticky and then push the five if I
go with d5 now let's do that we cannot
you cannot move both his lights that
that cannot be really good
you should switch out switch off the
mobile during the games it's not we
cannot i really cannot go afore because
this Queen F for coming but I can always
take their g4 and then be sure to fck
has 98 at the end things teas cannot go
if I that's really not it's really a bit
unfortunate that's not ideal maybe maybe
anyway Queen give five
queen queen bee three or something okay
shouldn't fall too far behind on the
clock that's a recipe for disaster okay
I didn't see that move not
the worst part is that I took so long
for the move it was forced anyway so I
don't really know why I spent so much
time on it check
time warning
maybe we'll keep one still there somehow
okay so he has yet anticipated animals
I am Groot chicks loss was a move so
yeah well it was certainly good for
white at some point but it doesn't help
you just outplayed me technically even
though it probably was was very good
food for me okay dad to get the pawn
however mmm it's got to rookie too okay
there's no choice i have to take that
rookie to i have to go look see ruchi
one crow me know that wolf I didn't see
that coming ah shoot f no I've known it
was just blundering blundering stuff
yeah okay like resides yeah okay well
around this is night age 5 and so on
that that's probably probably just just
not good but I did not refute it that's
its that's the thing so like this is
interesting geez 60 so that the engine
gives F for winning basically I thought
about that move but ah look see one is
also good to that's also good it's okay
it's pure tactics now and he's just
asked for that what am i doing I can
just take h5 come on after that I will
win it really even against this guy I'm
just as just an exchange up then and he
has a complete wreck of a position ah
that's just bad that's just very benches
and they take 30 seconds play Bishop f3
Wow
now what a shame yeah if they give you
the point on that silver plane you
should take idia and release this is
just just just just a bad setup and it
should exploit it but okay rook the aid
if he does not play rook da the thing is
not so clear Queenie 5 for example it's
not not not clear at all okay be surely
a five just wins the game nothing more
nothing less did you age five still good
but I didn't see g5 simply it was just
just that i didn't i didn't see the move
okay Bishop here night and then f4 is
still better but ok let's it's it's
difficult something like that that's
very complicated I always have this I'm
sorry Queen takes b6 when is Bishop
personal squares okay I didn't see that
it also was pure tactics I mean pure
calculation tippers just tons better
than I am b5 here here yeah I turn
doesn't help much really okay I said I
cannot take a jutsu arrow key to was
winning as well but that that's enough
winning a piece yeah I just played
better in the in the critical own faces
here when it was tactics I had this
opportunity with Bishop h5 to win
immediately and maybe like a maybe our
foreheads it would move but ok it's it's
difficult I'm threatening g4 winning
winning the piece there and I've
controlling GF I it's not a difficult to
play the engine gives that as the best
reply after which like this
basically toast that's terrible Wow yeah
okay that was a game of spoiled
opportunities okay well thanks for
watching